have you ever noticed that in almost
every action-packed movie a bad guy is
able to break in and steal a Priceless
piece of art or some expensive diamond
by finding that one security camera
blind spot well the same thing happens
in the cyber world hackers are trying to
break in by finding that one blind spot
that one vulnerability or weak link that
can they can take advantage of
the good guys the security analysts are
left fighting an uphill battle and they
are experiencing burnout
they are dealing with disconnected tools
sometimes hundreds of tools that are not
communicating with each other so they're
going back and forth checking all these
different tools
which by the way create hundreds if not
thousands of alerts daily
so what's a security analyst to do enter
Sim
it's one tool that outputs
High Fidelity
alerts
and we'll get back to this
in a second
so
what's a Sim
a Sim basically is a tool
that pulls in sources from
a whole bunch of different places
it Aggregates the data it consolidates
it and it sorts it to identify threats
it's the core threat protection
technology that most organizations use
on their war against hackers so
let's talk about what you can input into
your sim so you can have
um
logs
you can put in your threat Intel
you can put in your vulnerability feeds
you can put in your network detection
and response data and data from your
endpoint
um
and response tools so all of this is
going to be
integrated into your sim
and this is where the magic happens so
your sim is infused with AI
machine learning
and Analytics
and it's going to correlate all the
different data
from here
in real time so that it outputs a high
fidelity alert
and they're going to be prioritized by
severity
so you know which one needs immediate
attention
so what does high fidelity mean
High Fidelity High Fidelity is just a
fancy way of saying you're going to get
a better alert so let's talk about the
spy movie again say for instance a bad
guy is breaking into a museum to steal a
piece of work
and they cause a distraction in the
front of the museum but they're really
breaking in the back door so the false
positive that the Sim is weeding out is
the distraction in the front of the
museum
and the breaking in in the back is the
high fidelity alert so let me leave this
with you
regardless of your organization's size
threats are on the rise the bad guys are
not discriminating and they're using
highly sophisticated Technologies and
techniques to exploit vulnerabilities
across networks applications systems and
storage devices
simply put a SIM is a good guy's secret
weapon so I hope this is giving you a
clear understanding of what SIM is and
why it's important
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below